what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are man flash-forward dude up
okay Joshua Williams Matt Joshua
Williams said all right I already owe
Sean Murphy lunch and I don't see any
reason why we can't bring in bring in
Joshua Williamson dude Joshua Williamson
man have you ever saw bright in the
flash wouldn't be so pissed his work on
flash is nuts and this story is no
different and here's a funny thing it's
like the culmination of everything we've
been waiting for since like the
beginning of DC rebirth and the return
of classic Wally West it's like the one
thing we always wanted to see and
they're do there's so many great moments
of this okay okay so initially this
whole thing picks up with like flash and
Barry going to war right like that is
kind of like it gets each other and it's
like well if you're not gonna help me
then you know whatever like Wally West
is kind of freaking out on him but we're
not really given any context as to why
what we end up doing it's kind of
jumping back a little bit about or
really about it almost an hour earlier
and and just kind of picking up with
with this whole thing and this is kind
of cool because this is an exchange
between iris West and the new 52 Wally
West but the difference here is that
when it comes to like this exchange it's
different from the other ones that we've
seen because now iris is totally aware
of Wally right like that was look there
was the whole thing when Wally West when
classic Wally West first came back
red-haired Wally West when he first
reappeared we knew from just like the
history of DC that like he and IRS have
like a long-standing history because
they're family but when he first
appeared he didn't want to like
instigate a whole situation with Iris
and like reveal to her his identity and
so on and so forth and that was just
really like Williamson's way of working
into DC rebirth innocence their rebirth
is designed to bring back all the old
stuff and work it into all the new stuff
and kind of combine these two elements
together it created this idea that like
classic Wally West was back but we
didn't know how far out his you know his
his role would be and over the course of
the flash run and really it as far as
like the events and Titans and so on and
so forth we got these little tidbits
we're like little bits of classic Wally
West's past would kind of pop back up
again as it was kind of cool because
this this scenario is basically like
they're both aware of the idea of like
who classic Wally West is and in what's
going on with this guy and so on and so
forth and it's interesting because then
you have like Barry and and Wally who
basically show up having dealt with you
know a major issue and I've had just
kind of like race to this location and
it's one of the funny things because I
still say that Wally West is faster than
Barry but like it's a funny situation
right like because the way they're drawn
here it's awesome it's like it's like
it's like Ryu vs Ken like like who's
better and Street Fighter
Ryu or
and I say kin because it was like in the
old school Street Fighter games he was
faster I don't know if he's still faster
now I haven't played Street Fighter in
like ten years but still like like it's
interesting to me because what this does
is it starts to throw in this idea that
Wally West is getting a little more
extreme in terms of a length that he
will go to to try to like bring his pass
back and that works it's not like it's a
sudden shift that came on you know with
like this story it's been building up to
this you know the idea was that when
Wally first came back he was largely
hands-off but then he basically like he
met back up with the Titans and they all
remembered who he was and so from there
it was well I wonder who else will
Remember Who I am
and so it really became more of like a
like an obsession and we get these small
things here in there for example like in
this instance he remembers who he uh
Bart Thawne is and that's really kind of
a throwback to the return of Barry
Allen's story by Mark Waid you know back
in in really post 1984 after crisis on
Infinite Earths the flash stories were
taken up by a handful of people he had
like Mike Baron and and really like
barons Run was designed to kind of throw
Wally in this situation where he was
always under the shadow of Barry and it
was like well Barry died in crisis on
Infinite Earths and now you know I've
got to be the new flash and man it's
just so hard because I'm trying to live
up to the legacy of Barry but then when
Mark Waid took over
Wade Stan's was okay let's get this show
on the road because like people are
tired of seeing Wally under the the
shadow of Barry let's actually like make
Wally something cool and that's why Mark
Wayne's flash run is considered to be
like the run of the flash it's
solidified Wally but in one of the
earlier stories I would say the first
major like the first big story that Mark
Waid wrote was the return of Barry Allen
and it was basically like the
post-crisis on Infinite Earths origin of
eobard thawne the reverse flash and
that's cool because that's what this is
you're know Barry Allen like it's
literally this whole situation playing
out you have like Wally West who is part
of the Justice League you have like a
lot of these really cool moments and
that's the the interesting thing behind
this was like you can tell the Joshua
Williamson as a fan because these are
throwbacks two things that fans will
remember this is like a love letter to
all the fans of like classic Wally West
now at this point we pick up with the
arrival of the Renegades now we talked
about this and like the the the previous
Prelude video that we did to the events
of flash war which is basically that
like in the 25th century the Rogues
aren't really the ropes like the Rogues
don't really exist anymore what you have
is the Renegades who are basically like
good guys they're they're more of like a
police force of metahumans but when
you're yo classic Wally West and when
you're Barry Allen and you've never met
the Renny
or at least as far as you're aware
you've never met the Renegades you don't
see them as renegade you just see them
as like souped-up rogues and that it
just kind of like changed their name but
they still look the same and that's
exactly how they react and so it's kind
of cool because we're wall-e wes is
somewhat hot-headed very kind of steps
in and says no no we need to kind of
think things through now this is where I
would say Williamson seems to behave
more towards the post-crisis version of
the flash as opposed to Wally West when
we're talking about you know 2004 2005
2006 and the reason why I say that is
when Wally first became the flash under
like Mike Barron when he basically
stepped away from Kid Flash and replaced
buried he was a hothead in a lot of ways
but over the writing of Mark Waid and
like through the life experiences that
Wally had he became a lot more processed
he became a lot more wise this really
came as like a byproduct of not only
Linda Park and Wally's own kids but
things like impulse Bart Allen being
sent from the future into the past so
Wally could train him on how to use his
powers it came from wisdom that was
imparted by people like max mercury and
Jay Garrick so because the fact that
Wally was surrounded by so many you know
experienced speedsters he really began
to grow into his own and become a lot
more experienced in terms of what it
meant to be a flash and that you can't
just run into every situation without
really thinking about what's going on
and so that's where I would say this
kind of seems to be a bit of a
alteration from the Wally that we're
used to but it's not a bad thing because
this kind of feeds into the idea that
like Wally isn't really even sure what's
going on in his own life like he's
gaining memories all the time and so
where he remembers Linda Park maybe he
gains a memory later on where Linda Park
died and again it's kind of crazy
because he's basically remembering all
the things as they happened before 2011
so for the most part we kind of know how
this is gonna turn out with regards to
people who have been reading the flash
for quite some time or at least we have
a general idea but that's the beauty of
rebirth is just because we believe we
know how it's gonna turn out does it
mean it will turn out that way now of
course
Wally's response being a little more
hot-headed is know he takes iers anyway
any races off now this is cool because
with this situation you could look at
this and say well Iris is like the one
real thing the one real tangible thing
that Wally West remembers that he can
reach out and touch now because remember
he still keeps that barrier that
separation between himself and Linda
because the current day Linda doesn't
know who Wally is no it doesn't mean
that she won't I mean it took iris kind
of waking up to realize who Barry was
I'm sorry who who while he was and
there's nothing to say
the same thing won't happen with Linda
but we talked about this in the previous
videos the fear that Wally has with it
with Linda Park is that maybe he'll wake
her up and she'll freak out and leave
and like she'll abandon him she won't
embrace him with open arms like oh my
god I can't believe I forgot about you
should just be like okay this isn't too
much for me to handle and she'll leave
him and so it'll be like losing her all
over again that's really like the
biggest fear that he deals with the
other half of this and this is one of
the things that I love about Iris in the
comics is she's like get your hands off
of me it's so cool this is why I like
like I like iris in the TV show and iris
in the in the comics because it's there
they're very similar in terms of how
they work and so for the most part when
it comes to the to the renegades
basically chasing down you know like
like Wally and and iris and trying to
get a hold of very and like the new 52
Wally West and so on and so forth they
start kicking their powers and play and
that's when you learn that golden glider
is not like the golden glider that we
know this version is a yellow lantern
and that's awesome that's that's that's
super cool the other half of this though
is that it does kind of shift up the
nature of the yellow lanterns and it
does work because we've seen that in Hal
Jordan and the Green Lantern Corps right
like just because someone is real is
wielding a ring of Sinestro does not
mean they have to be a villain this is
not uncharted waters the other problem
with this though when it comes to Wally
is that while this is going on he keeps
getting these memory feats that are fed
in just these memories that keep coming
back and coming back and coming back and
that's something that I want you to
notice here they're coming at faster
intervals now it may just be the manner
in which Williamson's been telling these
stories and the way the stories are
being told in like Titans but the
general gist was that classic Wally West
came back in DC Universe rebirth number
one and then he would get a jolt of a
memory and then it would be like one or
two story arcs and then he would get
another one and then it'd be another one
or two story arcs and then he would get
another one now it's he gets one and
then BAM you know a couple minutes later
he gets one and then a couple minutes
later he gets one they're coming back
faster and faster and what this means is
that all these memories of Wally are
just pouring into his mind and so from
there what happens is basically
commander Cole stops everything he's
like look something's going on here
but our orders are to get iris West
bring her to the future put her on trial
for taking out eobard thawne and so
because of this like commander colas is
no pun intended he's kind of cold here
you know in the sense that he's like hey
look you know we'll help
Wally but like you need to come with us
you don't come with us while I didn't
get any help so you know make your
decision and it's kind of crazy here
because ultimately like they end up just
kind of going along you know all the
speeds
end up going with them because they
don't really trust the Renegades they
don't know anything about him it's this
group that looks like the Rogues that
appears from a temporal portal and says
you got to come with us you have to
believe us we're good guys there's no
reason to believe them and so classic
Wally Barry you know new 52 Wally West
and they all basically travel with Iris
and the Renegades to jump into the 25th
century the problem with this is that
when they get there everybody arrives
except for classic Wally and what we end
up finding out is somebody screwed with
the the temporal device of caffeine cult
so that Wally would be lost in transit
that's what we end up doing is
transitioning over to Wally himself in
what really looks kind of like a broken
remnants of the flash Museum and as he
goes through there he basically starts
getting these words from this guy and he
says like this is your life this is the
museum of your life this is everything
you've lost and this is when we start
getting like these amazing Easter eggs
like showing Wally West when he was kid
flash showing his first encounter with
impulse showing max mercury but once he
goes through here like this person says
like this is your entire life this is
everything you know Jay and iris West
the children of Wally are here they're
shown it kind of like a video feed of
sorts and so when the question is like
who are you what is going on here what
we end up getting is the return of
hunter zolomon and hunter zolomon is
amazing okay so
eobard thawne the original reverse flash
he goes all the way back to the 1970s
right like he's free crisis on Infinite
Earths once Christ on defenders happen
in 1985 1986 then we got like a new
version of eobard thawne and then
following that version of eobard thawne
geoff johns took over the flash story
and he gave us another reverse flash
named hunter zolomon now the difference
between a of our Thawne and hunter
zolomon is that we're a apart Thawne was
originally just like a massive fan of
the flash and then was obsessed with
very made himself look like Barry and
then traveled back into the past only to
find out you know Barry had died and
then look to the flash museum and
realized he was destined to become his
mortal enemy and went insane hunter
zolomon was totally different hunter
zolomon was basically a guy who was just
in the wrong place at the wrong time he
had a really really crappy upbringing he
was involved in a conflict lost the use
of his legs but he was a huge I would
say he worked alongside the flash more
so than anything else worked alongside
Barry as like a criminal profiler the
way he ended up becoming a villain was
because once he basically lost
everything that mattered to him he
basically went to the flash and said
like help me run back in time use your
cosmic treadmill help me run back in
time and fix everything that went wrong
like the flash said no and so because of
that hunter zolomon heart was filled
with anger and wrath of the fact that
the flash just wanted to hog all his
power to himself and so he basically
found a way to copy the powers of the
flash and he's been a villain ever since
but there's like history there and
that's why hunter zolomon says we were
friends once because they were they were
very good friends once they worked
alongside each other the relationship
between hunter zolomon and in wally west
is like the rebirth equivalent of august
heart and Barry Allen and the since that
August heart became godspeed because of
the fact that he was driven by a desire
to kind of fix everything hunter zolomon
motivations were a little bit different
but the pre villainous nature but I
guess the pre villainous relationship
between himself and Wally was almost
completely identical
now hunter's idea is you have to destroy
the Speed Force now we don't know what
effect that will have we don't know if
destroying the Speed Force will lead to
like the deaths of Jay Garrick and max
mercury and Johnny and Jesse chambers
and like giant iris West and like you
know impulse like all these characters
we don't know if that's going to be the
case instead all we know is it like this
Speed Force would be destroyed but
that's the question what lengths is
Wally willing to go to to not only bring
back all the speedsters who were there
at least presumably do that but also
basically go back and like return things
to the way they're supposed to be but
it's kind of cool here because remember
Barry Allen tried this during the events
of Flashpoint and that's what's screwed
everything up but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys have a sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoy this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]